und wir schauen auf den Protest im Iran
der ist so mutig so weiblich und so
wichtig dass wir Ihnen darüber immer und
immer wieder berichten wollen das sind
die Bilder die StudentInnen die
protestieren immer weiter lautstark die
nehmen ihr Kopftuch ab ja und schreien
kämpferisch setzen sich ein für ihre
Rechte für ihre Menschenrechte wollen
dass ich in ihrem Land auch hier auf
dieser Autobahnbrücke wo sie stehen dass
ich in ihrem Land endlich etwas ändert
sie haben die Nase gestrichen voll und
bringen sich in höchstem Gefahr mutige
iranische Schülerinnen gehen auf ihren
Schulleiter los bedrängen ihn brüllen in
nieder bis dieser nur noch das Weite
sucht
der Grund der Schulleiter hatte die
SchülerInnen aufgefordert ihre
Kopftücher zu tragen die sie aus Protest
abgelegt hatten
das Video aus seiner Schule interfresh
etwa 200 km südlich von Teheran geht
gerade um die Welt so wie unzählige
weitere Videos aus dem Iran die die
Proteste zeigen für mehr Frauenrechte
und gegen das mulla-regime
[Applaus]
Auslöser der Proteste gewesen ist der
Tod einer jungen Frau die von der
Sittenpolizei verhaftet worden und den
Gefängnis gestorben ist weil unter ihrem
Kopf hoch ein paar Strähnen
hervorgeschaut haben sollen weltweit
gibt es Sympathie Protestbewegungen wie
auch in Berlin
im Iran werden die Demonstranten vom
Regime brutal bekämpft knapp 130
Menschen sollen bislang ihr Leben
verloren haben
doch auch das hält diese furchtlosen
Schülerinnen nicht davon ab auch gegen
den Schulleiter weiter für ihre Rechte
zu protestieren
so mutige Frauen über die wir sprechen
bei uns im Studio ist jetzt unser Bild
Reporter Ehmann separty es auch
Menschenrechtsaktivist und deswegen sehr
sehr nah dran an diesem Thema desto von
Herzen begleitest was glaubst du nimmst
ein bisschen mit gestern vor der
Universität der hieß es das hier ist
nicht nur ein Protest das ist eine
Revolution die große Frage ist also wie
ist die Stimmung im Land wird es diesen
mutigen Frauen und auch Männern gelingen
etwas zu verändern die Stimmung ist
volle Optimismus auch wenn die Menschen
mit leere Hände da stehen die sind nur
enttäuscht dass westliche Politiker dem
aus demokratische Ländern leider nicht
viel machen aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
diese mutige iranische Frauen Männer
haben schon bereits gewonnen die Welt
hat erfahren dass diese Leute die die
Menschen satt von Islamische Republik
haben ein Republik die auf Scharia
aufgebaut ist und wir erwähnt die haben
schon bereits jetzt schon gewonnen
wir haben immer wieder die Frauen
angesprochen und tatsächlich es sind ja
auch Männer auf der Straße aber meistens
eben oder vorneweg diese mutigen Frauen
ich frag mich warum nicht noch viel mehr
Männer das ganze unterstützen geht der
Riss möglicherweise durch ganz viele
Ehen durch ganz viele Familien durch die
Frauen auf der Straße und die Männer
sitzen zu Hause und sagen unglaublich
was an meine Frau gerade macht ich muss
ehrlich das sagen am Anfang war viel
viele Frauen auf die Straße aber zum
ersten Mal in islamische Länder sind
Männer noch mit auf die Straße gegangen
die haben eigene vier Frauen Freundinnen
Geschwister oder Schwester nicht mehr
allein gelassen die sind mit auf die
Straße gegangen die wurden auch
mitgeschlagen und die haben gekämpft die
haben mitgekämpft und äh das Spiel geht
weiter und wie erwähnt wir werden Segen
weil diese mutige Frauen und Männer die
Straße nicht verlassen werden die werden
bis zuletzte Moment für Freiheit und
Menschenrechte im Iran kämpfen was kann
dabei helfen es wir jetzt ja auch dazu
gedrängt dass es mehr Sanktionen gibt
gegen die Mullahs glaubst du dass das
helfen kann und wie wird das im Iran
aufgefasst ja ich muss ehrlich sagen die
Menschen hören die ganze Zeit von wessen
vor allem von Frau bärburg mir
Sanktionen mir Sanktionen
das sind bis heute leider nur Worten
gewesen bis heute wurde leider nicht
viel gemacht die außerministerin Frau
bärbung ist bei uns Iran auch im Iran
viel bekannt eine Freundin erzählte mir
Feminismus der nicht global denkt ist
Egoismus Iraner bevor wurden mir
Sanktionen Sanktionen die eigentlich
direkt auch die rheinische Regierung und
deren Angehöriger trifft wenn wir uns
Zeit lassen wenn wir die Sanktionen
nicht
zielgerecht einsetzen dann spielen wir
eigentlich mit der Zukunft ein freies
Iran die iranische Botschafter der
allgemeine Botschafter der terror-regie
muss in Europa geschlossen werden das
sagen die Iraner auf die Straße gestern
Nacht haben die laut geschrien entweder
mit uns oder mit der iranische Regierung
die atomverhandlung mit iranischen
Regime muss aufhören und Bankkonto des
iranische Regime und deren angehören
muss auch
eingefroren werden genau wie bei Putin
und Russland wir müssen dieses Land
isolieren nur ein letzte Satz da ich
weiß dass wahrscheinlich auch Frau
Claudia Roth diese Sendung anschaut
viele westliche Politiker sind in
letzter Zeit voll verschleiert nach Iran
eingereist ein Appell an sie und alle
andere Politiker die Männer getroffen
haben die an Massen Hinrichtungen ähm
Frauen Vergewaltigung mitbeteiligt waren
ihr habt nicht nur weggeschaut ihr habt
leider auch mitgemacht ihr habt diese
Leute getroffen
es ist Zeit euch darüber zu äußern ein
Entschuldigung zu sagen an iranische
Frauen jetzt mutig auf die Straßen sind
und ihr Leben riskieren Tag für Tag
immerhin vielen herzlichen Dank für
Deinen Besuch hier bei uns im Studio ich
danke euch
[Musik]